ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen top
secret das steht auf den Papieren die
jetzt weltweit für Aufsehen sorgen ein
sehr ernstes Sicherheitsrisiko nennt es
das Pentagon also das amerikanische
Verteidigungsministerium viele Dokumente
die jetzt veröffentlicht wurden haben
mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine zu tun was
steht genau drin und welche Folgen haben
die leaks das ist heute unser Thema
meine und eure Fragen wie immer gerne in
die Kommentare heute gehen sie an den
Militärexperten Gustav gressel den holen
wir gleich dazu und an unsere
us-korrespondenten Elmar teven
bevor wir in die Kommentare gucken und
gemeinsam den Fragen nachgehen schauen
wir uns erst mal an worum es im Detail
geht
so sehen sie aus die Dokumente über
deren Echtheit und Herkunft sich die
Welt den Kopf zerbricht in den sozialen
Medien werden zahlreiche gefälschte
Versionen für Propaganda Zwecke
verbreitet viele der rund 100 geliebten
Papiere scheinen aber tatsächlich
hochsensible Daten zu enthalten glaubt
die US-Regierung
es gibt keine Entschuldigung dafür dass
solche Dokumente in der Öffentlichkeit
auftauchen
auf keinen Fall öffentlich sondern
streng geheim gehalten sein
vieles rund um die leaks ist nach wie
vor unklar was wir bisher wissen die
Dokumente bieten einen Einblick in die
lagebewertung des Krieges Anfang März
sie enthalten taktische Informationen
über die ukrainische Luftabwehr und die
internationalen Bemühungen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
unterstützen außerdem Hinweise auf
bisher unbekannte Möglichkeiten
russische militärkommunikation abzuhören
satellitenspionage wie das sogenannte
lapis-programm das wohl best gehütete
Geheimnis der US Luftaufklärung
unter Berufung auf die Dokumente
berichten sowohl die New York Times als
auch die Washington Post das US Militärs
an der Schlagkraft der geplanten früher
als Offensive der Ukraine zweifeln in
Kiew hingegen will man davon nichts
wissen und spielt die Veröffentlichungen
herunter die Suche nach dem Leck geht
weiter wie groß der Schaden am Ende
tatsächlich ist auch im Hinblick auf das
Vertrauensverhältnis zu den US
Verbündeten ist im Moment noch schwer
abzusehen
tja und dann gehen wir in die
vorsichtige Analyse arbeiten mit dem was
wir schon wissen und vor allem was unser
US-Korrespondent Studioleiter in
Washington dazu zu sagen hat MRT wissen
du bist uns jetzt zugeschaltet aus
Belfast weil du gerade den
amerikanischen Präsidenten auf seiner
Nordirland Reise begleitest welche Rolle
spielt das denn da in der Delegation wie
groß ist die Aufregung in den USA über
das Thema
also in der Delegation redet man ganz
offenbar lieber nicht darüber weil das
natürlich eine Menge Probleme bereitet
für die US-Regierung zu erklären wie
kann es eigentlich sein dass so geheime
Papiere und ein Teil davon ist mit
Sicherheit authentisch hören wir aus dem
Weißen Haus und aus dem Pentagon das
solche Papiere einfach an die
Öffentlichkeit kommen deswegen schweigt
der Präsident weitgehend dazu aber in
den Briefings in Washington wird ständig
darüber geredet weil man natürlich
herausbekommen will woher kommen diese
Unterlagen und es ermittelt nicht nur
das Pentagon sondern auch das
amerikanische Justizministerium ist
eingeschaltet denn im schlimmsten Fall
aus amerikanischer Sicht er handelt es
sich ja möglicherweise um einen
Geheimnis Verrat also müsste ein
Verräter in den eigenen reingesucht
werden und genau diese Ermittlungen
laufen aber die richten sich natürlich
nicht nur gegen amerikanische
Mitarbeiter der Regierung sondern auch
gegen jeden anderen der vielleicht in
Frage kommt diese Dokumente gestohlen
und dann veröffentlicht zu haben
immer wenn ich hier in die Chats gucke
dann sehe ich sehr viele Fragen zum
Thema Echtheit also ganz viele Userinnen
und User fragen sich sind diese
Dokumente überhaupt echt hier fragt
einer
die Frage ist doch sind sie echt und
wenn ja wie konnte das passieren und
Felix fragt über Youtube wie so ein
datenlack überhaupt zustande kommt und
was das Pentagon jetzt dagegen
unternehmen will lass uns erstmal bei
der Echtheit bleiben welche
Schlüssel liegen nahe dass diese
Dokumente echt sein können
also das sagen nicht einfach wir obwohl
auch wir ich sag mal ein Dutzend dieser
Dokumente einsehen konnten bzw nicht die
Dokumente selber sondern es handelt sich
ja um Fotografien von Dokumenten die
sind also abfotografiert und dann eben
verbreitet worden und das sieht nicht
nur authentisch aus sondern ist
mittlerweile aus amerikanischen
Regierungskreisen bestätigt es handelt
sich tatsächlich um streng geheime
Unterlagen aus den unterschiedlichsten
Feldern der amerikanischen Aufklärung
nicht nur rund um den UK keine Krieg
sondern auch gegenüber anderen Staaten
rund um den Erdball also ein Großteil
der Dokumente wird als authentisch
angesehen aber sie sind eben seit Anfang
März und auch das ist sehr überraschend
seit Anfang März sind diese Dokumente
schon auf einer chat-plattform zur
Verfügung gestanden discord heißt die
das eine Plattform die besonders Gamer
nutzen und dann konnten diese Dokumente
ganz offenbar auch von Menschen
heruntergeladen und auch verändert
werden und so bagabundieren mittlerweile
unterschiedliche Versionen dieser
Dokumente oder der Fotografien durch die
Welt und da kann man eindeutig sehen
dass es eben
Veränderungen gab zum Beispiel was die
Zahl der Opfer im Ukraine Krieg bis zum
Ende des Februar dieses Jahres eben
angeht da sind die Zahlen andere als die
in den wahrscheinlich Originalunterlagen
gewesen sind also gibt es eine Reihe von
Anhaltspunkten aber es ändert nichts da
dran auch wenn jemand versucht ist
Informationen zu streuen dass ein
Großteil dieser Dokumente das bestätigt
die amerikanische Regierung tatsächlich
eigentlich streng geheime
staatsdokumente sind dann lass uns noch
mal darüber sprechen du hast es gerade
gesagt dass diese Dokumente schon lange
im Netz sind schon mehrere Monate und
vor allem offenbar auf Plattformen die
von Gamern genutzt werden und so ein
bisschen durch Zufall
kamen die jetzt an die breitere
Öffentlichkeit was lässt uns denn das
Lernen über den der möglicherweise
hinter diesem lieg steckt
also wenn man sich die Vielzahl der
Dokumente und die unterschiedlichen
Themen anschaut hat man fast den
Eindruck da hat irgendeiner eine große
Tasche mit Geheimunterlagen gefunden hat
sie dann alle abfotografiert und wo
kommt so eine Tasche Zustande also wo
sind briefing-unterlagen beispielsweise
gesammelt worden von irgendjemanden der
sie mit anderen Unterlagen privaten
Unterlagen möglicherweise vermischt
hatte findet sich nämlich unter diesen
Fotos auch eines das zeigt ein ein
Magazin ein jägermagazin das eigentlich
überhaupt nichts mit der
nachrichtenaufklärung der USA zu tun hat
aber das diente ganz offenbar auch ein
Stück weit als Unterlage unter einigen
dieser abfotografierten Dokumente weil
man sieht immer ein kleines Stück von
diesem jägermagazin auch mal rausloggen
aus diesen fotografieren also man kann
daraus schließen dass offenbar jemand
ein Fund gemacht hat vielleicht aber
auch das gezielt gesammelt hat und das
ist dann eben Anfang März also nicht
seit mehreren Monaten sondern seit mehr
als einem Monat mittlerweile über
discord verbreitet worden und das macht
auch ein Stück weit den Eindruck als
wäre da nicht von vorne herein gezielt
Desinformationen oder auch Sabotage in
irgendeiner Weise betrieben worden
sondern auch das ist eine mögliche
Theorie wir müssen da sehr vorsichtig
sein eine Theorie dass jemand eben diese
Unterlagen bekommen hat und fand es
einfach cool sie zu verbreiten hat
vielleicht auch gar nicht drüber
nachgedacht was für ein Schaden das
anrichtet also ob das mit böse Absicht
passiert ist ob man vor allen Dingen den
USA damit schaden wollte und die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sabotieren
wollte auch daran gibt es Zweifel denn
es werden auch sehr sensible Daten
beispielsweise über Russland also den
Angreifer in diesen Krieg dachte
aufgelistet also insgesamt noch sehr
unübersichtlich und deswegen arbeitet
eine große Zahl von Ermittlern daran
während man gleichzeitig dafür sorgt
dass bei allen Gelegenheiten wo
vielleicht solche Dokumente eingesehen
werden können wo sie ich sag mal bei
einem Briefing ausgeteilt werden am
Tisch auf Papier das solche Dokumente
eben nicht mehr ausgeteilt werden dass
man also den Zugang zu solchen geheimen
Informationen beschränkt das ist jetzt
seit vier fünf Tagen im Gange das heißt
man schraubt die Zahl derer die Zugang
haben massiv runter und auch das schadet
natürlich ein Stück weit dem wichtigen
Austausch von Erkenntnissen der eben die
Grundlage dafür bietet dass man z.B der
Ukraine in diesem Krieg optimale Hilfe
bieten kann
bevor wir gleich noch mal auf die
Inhalte eingehen auch dazu gibt es viele
Fragen und dann noch mal dezidiert auf
die Folgen auch für den Ukraine Krieg
ähm lass uns noch mal dabei bleiben was
das Pentagon jetzt macht du hast es
gerade schon angedeutet hier gibt's zwei
Fragen dazu Felix wie gesagt fragt über
Youtube was will das Pentagon jetzt
dagegen unternehmen und Sven Odendahl
fragt über Facebook an solche Dokumente
kommen ja nur ganz bestimmte Kreise ran
weiß man schon wer sie veröffentlicht
hat also was genau wird jetzt
unternommen es waren ja offenbar relativ
viele die möglicherweise Zugang zu
diesem Dokumenten gehabt haben können
also ich will mal so formulieren dass
die Unterlagen so wild dieses Bündel
auch ist vielleicht tatsächlich
Gegenstand eines Workshops gewesen sein
könnte also einer Veranstaltung bei der
die Teilnehmer dann zu den
unterschiedlichen Aspekten der
amerikanischen Aufklärung solche
Unterlagen ausgeteilt bekommen haben ein
Workshop der vielleicht nicht nur eine
halbe Stunde gedauert hat sondern sich
auch über einen Tag oder zwei erstreckt
hat ein Beispiel dafür wäre vorhanden
Anfang März ist tatsächlich solch ein
Workshop hat stattgefunden in Ramstein
in Deutschland das bedeutet nicht dass
es da passiert sein muss aber es sind
natürlich Hinweise darauf dass man bei
solchen Veranstaltungen möglicherweise
viel zu vielen Menschen Zugang zu diesem
geheimen Informationen gegeben hat und
deswegen geht das Pentagon hin und sorgt
jetzt dafür dass bei solchen ich sag mal
Ausbildungen Fortbildungen Workshops
oder Briefings die stattfinden
möglicherweise auch für befreundete
streitkr für Verbündete alliierte dass
man dann massiv einschränkt wer so etwas
bekommt zweitens in welcher Form er es
bekommt ob möglicherweise eben nicht
alle Informationen weitergereicht werden
und schon gar nicht auf Papier und es
wird auch sehr genau nachgeguckt was man
vielleicht aus diesen jetzt vorhandenen
Fotos ja schließen kann weil wer immer
das gepostet hat hat sich offenbar gar
keine große Mühe gemacht alles zu
verschleiern auch da kann man
elektronisch forensisch herausfinden
beispielsweise
wenn die Daten in diesen Fotos noch
vorhanden sind die original Daten wann
wurde das Foto gemacht
möglicherweise auch geologischen Daten
enthalten sind das ist bei manchen
fotogeräten ja der Fall bei unseren
Handys z.B dass das mit aufgezeichnet
wird und ganz offenbar hat der Täter ich
nenne den jetzt mal so oder die
Tätergruppe oder die Täterin nicht daran
gedacht dass diese Fotos möglich
teilweise wertvolle Hinweise auf die
Urheberschaft liefern können das wird
ausgewertet auch wie das verbreitet
worden ist über diese Plattform discord
auch da kann man möglicherweise
herausfinden wer hat das zuerst
vorbereitet über welche IP-Adressen also
Geräte Computer wurde das tatsächlich in
diese Netzwerke hinein verbreitet also
da läuft jetzt hinter den Kulissen auch
eine fieberhafte Fahndung nachdem oder
derjenigen die möglicherweise das
tatsächlich veröffentlicht haben
immer ich sehe hier gerade einen
Kommentar von Uwe mobil der dankbar ist
für deine Einschätzung in 130 kann man
das nicht unterbringen sehr
aufschlussreiche Aussagen von Herrn
thewesen das möchte ich Dir gerne
weitergeben und dann die Frage die
natürlich viele Userinnen und User
bewegt an Dich weitergeben Markus
Stiepel fragt über Youtube Elmar was
steht denn drin
oh das ist ein unglaubliches Konglomerat
es steht einerseits sehr viel natürlich
über den Ukraine Krieg und die
Erkenntnisse die man hat über die
russische Aufstellung auch über die
ukrainische Ausstellung drin dann gibt
es eine Art zweiten Kreis das sind
Erkenntnisse über Länder die in
irgendeiner Weise möglicherweise
die Ukraine oder Russland unterstützen
oder unterstützen könnten will mal ein
Beispiel nennen da steht beispielsweise
drin dass Südkorea von den USA abgehört
oder überwacht worden ist und Südkorea
ist ein Verbündeter der USA und dabei
offenbar Erkenntnisse abgeschöpft wurden
dass man darüber nachdachte wie kann man
verhindern dass man Munition direkt an
die Ukraine liefert dass man also unter
Druck gesetzt wird von den USA Munition
dorthin zu liefern weil einem das nicht
recht war man wollte das Verhältnis mit
Russland nicht zu sehr belasten da ist
vielleicht nicht der Inhalt das
keine soll es entscheidende dass hier
klar wird dass die USA ganz offenbar ein
Verbündeten Abhören das ist nicht ganz
neu das tun sie schon seit vielen
Jahrzehnten aber immer wieder wenn so
was passiert sät das natürlich Streit
und Misstrauen ein zweites Beispiel
ägypten ist ein sehr enger strategischer
Partner auch für die USA im Nahen und
Mittleren Osten das Land wurde in den
letzten Jahren mit einer Millionen
Milliarde Dollar an Waffen unterstützt
aus den USA und nun gibt es tatsächlich
in den Unterlagen ein Dokument das
jedenfalls behauptet dass der Präsident
Assisi in einem Gespräch mit seinem
militärischen Befehlshabern angeordnet
habe über 40.000 Raketen herstellen zu
lassen die man dann an Russland liefern
wollte ohne dass der Westen ohne dass
die USA die Verbündeten davon erfahren
offenbar hat dieser Deal nicht
stattgefunden der wird auch von den USA
bestritten dass es dann tatsächlich zur
so etwas gekommen ist nicht dritten wird
dass da offenbar ein Gespräch abgehört
belauscht vielleicht war einer dabei der
hinterher das weitergegeben hat das sind
Erkenntnisse die reichen weit über den
unmittelbaren ukrainekrieg hinaus und es
geht noch einen Schritt weiter das wäre
der dritte Kreis Erkenntnisse die
eigentlich gar nichts mit der Ukraine zu
tun haben auch da will ich ein Beispiel
nennen in einem Dokument wird
beschrieben dass der israelische
Geheimdienst Mossad und zwar die
führenden Leute im Mozart selber dazu
aufgefordert haben und den Rat gegeben
haben dass man auf die Straße
demonstrieren gehen soll gegen die
Justizreform die benjamin hat halt net
dann ja oder Premierminister in Israel
durchziehen will also das ganz offenbar
in der Führungsstruktur der israelischen
Geheimdienste
Opposition gegen den Premierminister
gemacht wird steht in einem Dokument
drin hat nichts mit Ukraine zu tun aber
hat natürlich jetzt schon Auswirkungen
der muss halt selber bestreitet dass und
man spielt das natürlich auch ein Stück
weit runter weil man eben auch einfach
sagen kann das ist Desinformationen das
ist der Teil der Dokumente der
eigentlich nicht stimmt aber es lässt
sich für uns jedenfalls als Beobachter
momentan nicht herausfinden was wirklich
authentisch ist und was stimmt und was
möglicherweise nachträglich verändert
oder hinzugefügt worden ist
also immer wir sehen dass es bereits
jetzt große Auswirkungen hat dass es für
viel Verunsicherung sorgt weltweit im
Verhältnis der USA zu verschiedenen
Staaten die du gerade genannt hast dann
blicken wir jetzt mal genauer auf das
Verhältnis zur Ukraine und zu den
folgenden die die Veröffentlichungen auf
den Ukraine kriegt haben können und dazu
nehmen wir Gustav gressel mit in die
Runde dazu habe ihn vorhin schon
angekündigt Gustav gressel die Userinnen
und User kennen ihn wenn sie oft hier
bei uns im Stream mit dabei sind
Politikwissenschaftler und Experte für
Fragen mit Fokus auf
Osteuropa und Russland am European
counsel und fallen relations in Berlin
welche Auswirkungen haben aus ihrer sich
diese Veröffentlichungen auf den Ukraine
kriegt
also unmittelbar es sind natürlich die
Auswirkungen nicht so groß weil vieles
was da drin steht auf die eine oder
andere Weise bekannt oder offenes
Geheimnis ist also zum Beispiel dass die
Ukraine Probleme hat
Munition aufzutreiben ist jetzt nicht
etwas was
Leute überraschen sollte das steht in
der Zeitung ukrainische Präsident
Verteidigungsminister Premierminister
geht doch die Welt und wird für
Unterstützung für Zuwendungen mit immer
Verweis auf den knapp munitionsbestand
was dann natürlich das andere ist sind
genaue Zeit leisten wann gewisse
munitionsklassen ausgehen das könnte
russischen militärischen Planern
natürlich helfen ihre eigenen
Operationen dementsprechend hinzu planen
dass man in die Erschöpfung gewisser
munitionsklassen hineinplant da fragt
sich nur wie akkurat sind diese
Schätzungen sonst muss man auch sagen
wir wissen noch nicht
was der Gesamtumfang dieser Dokumente
ist wir kennen das was ins Netz gestellt
wird wir wissen aber nicht auf
vielleicht auch Teile des Bundes unter
der Hand irgendwo weiterverkauft werden
wurden ob wirklich alles veröffentlicht
wurde und solange wir natürlich diesen
Gesamtumfang der sozusagen verlorenen
oder
kompromittierten Informationen können
ist natürlich auch ganz schwer
abzuschätzen welche langfristige
Tragweite das für diesen Kriegen wird
wirklich hat
dann lassen Sie uns unabhängig vom
Inhalt mal auf das blicken was man jetzt
sagen kann zum Verhältnis zwischen der
Ukraine und den USA die Frage geht an
beide ich fange mal bei Ihnen an Herr
gressel inwiefern belastet es das
Verhältnis und die Unterstützung der
Ukraine durch die Amerikaner
weiß man natürlich darauf hin dass
eigentlich immer der Vorwurf an die
Ukraine kam es könnte sozusagen die
Ukraine ein Hort von Geheimnis Verrat
werden man sollte nicht zu moderne
Technik an die Ukraine liefern man
sollte nicht zum moderne Waffen liefern
etc diese Argumentation kam mir Zuge der
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern und anderen
modernen waffengeräte immer wieder auf
die Ukraine zu und da sieht man jetzt
natürlich schon mit einem gewissen
Schmunzeln dass man nicht selber also
der Orte ist an dem so ein Lapsus
passiert ist sondern dass das die waren
die einem vorher angemahnt hätten man
sollte darauf aufpassen dass
das Hauptproblem
hier ist
die die diplomatische Front es gibt ja
viele Einschätzungen in diesem Papieren
die nahelegen dass man im Washington
nicht auch in einer großen Erfolg
dagegenoffensive glaubt dass man im
Grunde ein einen
Waffenstillstand auf gegenwärtigen
Linien für das wahrscheinlichste
Resultat hält und das ist für die
Ukraine beunruhigenden zweierlei
Hinsicht erstens mal ist Russland nicht
zu seinem Waffenstillstand zum
gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt bereit und man
hat Angst dass sozusagen die die
Unterfüllung in diesbezüglich dann die
Ukraine in diesem langen Krieg vor
erhebliche Natur Probleme stellen wird
das zweite ist dass selbst wenn das
eintreten sollte für die Ukraine vor
allen Dingen zu den gegenwärtigen Linien
das natürlich die wirtschaftliche
Überlebensfähigkeit und mehr oder zur
Hälfte russisch kontrolliert wird dann
schon sehr in Frage gestellt ist da
stell sie jetzt natürlich für Sie Lenski
auch die Frage
sind sind die geringen Anlieferungen
oder die Waffenlieferungen die ein
bisschen unter den Erwartungen der
Ukraine sind Teil dieser Skepsis oder
sind die Teile eines Plans dies in
diesen Kriegs sozusagen auf der
Punktlandung Minsk 3 Abkommen oder warum
verstehst dann Abkommen zu landen und
wie geht man mit so mit Verbündeten um
die zu öffentlich sagen wir unterstützen
die Ukraine solange es nötig ist und mit
was auch immer sie braucht aber
praktisch natürlich sozusagen ich hier
hinter verschlossenen Türen einen
eigenen Geheimdokumenten andere
Zielvorgaben für diesen Kriegers als
dass das wahrscheinlichste oder unter
der Hand vielleicht sogar angeschrieben
sehen das dürfte noch für einige
Diskussionen sagen
immer wie groß ist der Schaden den die
USA da jetzt haben als Unterstützer der
Ukraine
also ich glaube zweierlei das eine ist
natürlich dürfte die Ukraine schon sehr
sauer sein weil ihnen in den letzten 12
oder 14 Monaten ist sehr darauf ankam so
wenig wie möglich Informationen auch an
die amerikanischen Partner
beispielsweise zu geben über die Lage
die ganz konkret an der Front sich
entwickelt hatte man hat nicht alle
Informationen mit den amerikanischen
Partnern geteilt und schon gar nicht mit
weiteren und dass das jetzt passiert ist
das beispielsweise in Moskau der
Eindruck entstehen kann zu diesem
Zeitpunkt ist die Munition alle und zu
diesem Zeitpunkt hat die Ukraine auch
keine luftabwehrmöglichkeit mehr und
damit nach Moskau das Signal zu senden
wenn man dann noch durchhält und noch
mal nachlegen kann dann hat man Chancen
auf Erfolg während vielleicht ansonsten
zu diesem Zeitpunkt man schon zu dem
Schluss gekommen wäre man zieht sich
wenigstens wieder ein Stück weiter
zurück um sich neu zu sortieren das ist
das eine und das zweite und das
vielleicht das noch viel gravierender
weil alles ist ja eher ein Schnappschuss
gewesen zum ersten März diesen Jahres
aber einiges geht darüber hinaus und das
betrifft die Erkenntnisse die Moskau
gewinnen kann über die
aufklärungsfähigkeiten der USA ganz
offenbar sind die USA in der Lage durch
neueste Satellitentechnologie so genaue
Aufnahmen zu machen und durch abgehörte
Gespräche durch abgehörte Kommunikation
möglicherweise auch durch menschliche
Quellen innerhalb des russischen
Militärs und innerhalb des russischen
Regierungsapparates so konkrete
Informationen zu haben dass man
gewissermaßen vorhersagen konnte oder
genau sagen konnte welche Pläne Moskau
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
umsetzen wollte das Moskau das jetzt
weiß wie gut diese
aufklärungskapazitäten sind kann
natürlich auch dazu führen dass man
versucht diese Aufklärungsmethoden zu
unterlaufen zum Beispiel durch
elektronische Störsignale dass man auch
gezielt auf die Jagd noch mal nach
Maulwürfen geht also schaut wer hat da
Informationen weitergegeben und damit
könnte eben Moskau sich besser schützen
vor solchen
Aufklärungsmaßnahmen und das könnte eben
auch mittelfristig massive Auswirkungen
auf die Frühjahrsoffensive der Ukraine
haben also man ist das hören wir aus
Washington in Kiew überhaupt nicht
erfreut auch wenn man nach außen hin
auch versucht natürlich diese ganzen
Dokumente ein Stück weit
herunterzuspielen
wenn ich hier in die Kommentare gucke
dann greifen die Userinnen und User
genau das auf was sie beide sagen und
fragen sich ist das vielleicht eine
große
Nebelkerze wer fängt hier was wer führt
hier wen in die Irre wer profitiert hier
denn eigentlich also any MC fragt z.B
über Youtube kann das ganze auch ein
Fake sein um die Russen in die Irre zu
führen sorry die fragt auch über Youtube
könnte es sich dabei womöglich um eine
Art Falle des amerikanischen
Geheimdienstes handeln um die Russen zu
verwirren und wie gesagt die Frage nach
der Nebelkerze weil da war rief über
Youtube fragt auch ich weiß abwegig aber
könnten diese leaks auch absichtlich
sein um eine riesige Nebelkerze zu
streuen Herr gräßel
glaube ich eher nicht das Interessante
an diesem Karten oder den Aufzählungen
ist ja das die amerikanische Aufklärung
viel genauer weiß was auf der russischen
Seite davon passiert als was auf der
ukrainischen Seite davon passiert und
russischer Seite kann man natürlich die
Angaben über sich selbst relativ gut
nach prüfen und sozusagen perfekt
checken wie man das auf neudeutsch sagt
also ich glaube nicht dass man die
russische Seite über ihr eigenes
dispositiven Absichten verwirren könnte
die wissen schon was sie haben und was
sie was sie befohlen bekommen die
Angaben über die Ukraine die sind
großteils Waage und dort wo sie konkret
werden ist es vor allen Dingen wenn es
um munitionsbestand von pflegeabwehr
geben geht problematisch
da glaube ich aber auch nicht dass das
eine große Ewigkeit ist dass hier
sozusagen irgendwo noch große Munition
verräte in der Hinterhand stehen und man
sozusagen die russische Luft war für
deinen Hinterhalt locken können wird
dafür gibt es einfach für die für die
tatsächlich hier diskutierten
Waffensysteme wirklich am Weltmarkt zu
wenigen Munition um irgendwo sozusagen
der spaßbestände irgendwas aufzukaufen
weiterzugeben man hat die Ukraine unter
der Hand doch etwa abgefangene
schmugellieferungen durch auf dem
Schwarzmarkt aufgekauft der Bestände und
versuchsbestände aus den USA noch eine
Zeit
durchfüttern können aber dass das Ganze
enden wollen ist das hat man im Grunde
letzten Herbst auch schon gewusst ja das
Problem ist wie gesagt also das genau
vorschreiben von Zeitleisten dass das
ist auch ukrainischer Sicht natürlich
sehr bitter ansonsten muss ich auch
sagen auch was über die gegen Offensive
ausgebaut werden genau das möchte ich
gerne wollte ich als nächstes aufwerfen
das Wort früher als Offensive ist schon
gefallen dazu gibt es auch viele Fragen
Eduard Kuhn fragt haben die leaks einen
Einfluss darauf ob die Offensive noch im
April stattfinden kann
würde ich sagen ist es
ausbildungstechnischen Gründen ist ja
unwahrscheinlich dass sie noch statt
wird und das zweite aus Wetter Wetter
Sicht also jetzt ist sozusagen unter
Anführungszeichen oder es gab
jetzt recht feuchtes Wetter
schneeschnelze ist ist am komplizieren
das zweite ist natürlich die Ukraine
Jahres viele westliche Waffensysteme
bekommen da war die Einzel die Zugs die
Kompanie Ausbildung im Westen des
abgeschlossen ist werden die Bataillone
und diese speziellen sturmbrigaden
zusammengestellt in der Ukraine die
müssen noch verbandstraining absolvieren
bis sie sozusagen eingeschweißte
Verbände sind und sich aneinander
gewöhnt haben bis man unterschiedliche
Waffensysteme von unterschiedlichen
Geber Nationen auch aufeinander
einspielt und erst dann während diese
privaten angriffsbereit das wird sowieso
bis meine Dauer
das zweite ist ihnen Dokumenten wird
über diese Gegend Offensive relativ
wenig gesagt das was an Kräften bereits
steht und was an Waffenlieferungen
gekommen ist das kann man im Grunde aus
der Presse auch
zusammenstellen wenn man auch beobachtet
welche
ukrainischen Verbände nicht mehr
in den Front berichten vorkommen welche
also scheinbar aus der Front rausgezogen
sind dann kann man natürlich vermuten
dass diese Verbände an der
Gegenoffensive teilnehmen und padouts
das sind dann auch die die zumindest
auch in der Größe in diesen Dokumenten
genannt werden also wie gesagt diese
Information hätte man sich eigentlich
aus öffentlichen der Dokumenten auch
zusammen suchen können und es ist ja
noch nichts über den Zeitpunkt und vor
allen Dingen auch nicht über die genaue
Angriffsrichtungen der ukrainischen
gegen Offensive in diesen Dokumenten
bekannt also zumindest in dem Teil von
denen wir wissen und das ist ja
eigentlich das was die Ukraine am
allermeisten geheim halten will wann und
wohin mit welcher Richtung und welchen
Angriffsziel sie eigentlich los schlagen
will
ich würde gerne mit einer letzten Frage
an Elmar Tierwesen unseren USA Chaos von
hinten aus dem Stream verabschieden
immer letzte Frage an dich was ist deine
Einschätzung kommt da noch mehr
also es ist nicht auszuschließen weil
wir wissen aus dem jetzt vorhandenen
Material das da Lücken drin sind wo es
eigentlich Sinn macht dass da noch mehr
sein könnte ich will aber zum Thema
Nebelkerzen auch noch mal klar sagen aus
amerikanischer Sicht macht das überhaupt
keinen Sinn weil der Flurschaden für die
USA jetzt schon riesig ist nicht nur das
verbündete sich aufregen nicht nur dass
es möglicherweise auch Einfluss auf das
Kriegsgeschehen hat nicht nur dass man
selber ja unter Druck gerät politisch
dadurch weil ganz klar muss man ja
fragen wie kann man so naiv und so
leichtsinnig sein solches streng geheime
Material irgendwie ähm per Papier
gewissermaßen so zu verteilen das ist
dann am Ende einfach mal über so eine
Plattform verbreitet werden kann und
wenn es am Ende auch nur irgendjemand
gefunden hat der sich cool dabei vorkam
und sich keine größeren Gedanken darüber
gemacht hat aber vielleicht war es auch
gezielt jemand der tatsächlich allen
Beteiligten schaden wollte unmittelbar
da kann man viel spekulieren wer das
sein könnte also hier ist jedenfalls die
Sorge groß in der US-Regierung und eben
in Washington im Pentagon und im
Justizministerium wo das herkommt könnte
noch mehr sein und man will natürlich um
jeden Preis verhindern dass diese
Dokumente einfach mal so wieder
auftauchen und erst recht will man
verhindern dass sie dann Tage vielleicht
wochenlang in den Netzwerken geteilt
werden und zur Verfügung stehen um damit
möglicherweise auch weiter
Desinformationen zu betreiben
dann sage ich an dieser Stelle vielen
Dank Elma tewesen in diesem Fall nach
Belfast danke dass du bei uns im Stream
dabei warst
ja Herr gressel MRT Wissen hat es jetzt
ausgeführt es gibt viele denen diese
Veröffentlichungen Schaden anders
herumgefragt kui Bono wer hat denn was
von diesen Veröffentlichungen
ist eine gute Frage
sie stiften auf jeden Fall Verwirrung im
Westen da kann man natürlich annehmen
das sozusagen das Russland zu einem
gewissen Teil nützt natürlich
wenn es ein reinrussisches Lied wäre
würden wahrscheinlich seine Vorbereitung
wie wir es ja in den vergangenen Tagen
auch gesehen werden das Dokumente
nachträglich verfälscht worden im Wald
stärkerem Ausmaß
vorhanden sein das heißt hier sind
zurzeit würde ich sozusagen mit der
Frage cool Bruno die man hinten
anstellen das sind noch viel zu viele
Eckpunkte dieses ganzen Geschehens noch
umkehrt
es kann also jetzt sag mal ganz böse
gesagt viele diese Dinge also entweder
es war jemand der sich cool vorkommt
viele Dinge
Geheimnis verräte etc passieren aber
auch aus inner bürokratischen
Flüssigkeiten dass sich Leute bei
Beförderungen über anderen Dingen
übergangen sehen und dann aus ganz
persönlichen Motiven Organisationen
Schaden zufügen
oder oder ein Vorgesetzten an sich im
rechnen wollen alle diese Dinge die die
für uns aus objektiver Sicht komplett
lächerlich sind die spielen dann bei so
einer individuellen Motivation von
Leuten an die Öffentlichkeit mit
gewissen Dingen zu gehen oder
Informationen einen anderen Land oder
einem anderen Geheimdienst anzuvertrauen
eine erhebliche Rolle und all das wissen
wir zurzeit noch nicht und deshalb ist
es da würde ich mich dann nicht an
Spekulationen beteiligen kommen wir noch
mal auf die Auswirkungen auf die Ukraine
zurück an die MAC fragt welchen Einfluss
haben die Daten auf den Kriegsverlauf
verschlechtert sich die Situation der
Ukraine dadurch
also unmittelbar würde ich eher sagen
nein weil eben viele dieser Dinge
bekannt und berechenbar sind mittelbar
ist es natürlich auch ein schlechtes
Zeichen also das erste ist es wurde mal
eine gewisse Hybris aufgedeckt von dem
man natürlich auch da gab es Interviews
schauen da gab es schon Artikel auch in
der amerikanischen Presse dass die
beiden Administrationen öffentlich sich
sozusagen zu einem entschlossen eine
Hilfe der Ukraine bekennt also dass also
das sozusagen
dann auch im
militärischen Unterstützungsbereich und
wirklich umsetzt diese wurde aufgeworfen
und da braucht natürlich Russland schon
stark her und sagt
dass die Unterstützung im Westen die ist
nicht so unumstoßbar wie hier getan wird
vielleicht müssen wir einfach hier noch
Zahn zulegen oder wir müssen das noch
ein zwei Jahre aussetzen dann schaut das
anders aus das zweite ist eben dass man
wenn man wenig oder keine Informationen
hat was ein ukrainischen
munitionsbestand ist was am ukrainischen
Kräfte Dispositiv da ist und wenn man im
russischen geheimdienstapparaten das
auch eine alte russische Sitte den Feind
immer maßlos überschätzt indem man jede
jedes Gerücht dass man irgendwo
aufschnappt von Waffenlieferungen sofort
für bare Münze hält und sofort für
umgesetzt hält
dass man sich da sozusagen irgendwann
selbst abschreckt indem man den Gegner
für größer und mächtiger hält also
eigentlich ist dass man natürlich jetzt
durch diese Folien dann eher wieder
Richtung Tatsachen korrigiert wurde und
dann sich natürlich in einem langen
abnutzungskrieg schon
ausrechnet den auch über lange Sicht
gewinnen zu können wenn man das was an
ukrainischen Potenzial noch da ist
Matten wird können und das könnte der
Ukraine über den Sommer vor allen Dingen
sollte diese Gegend Offensive eben nicht
zu einem durchschlagenden Erfolg werden
durchaus noch stark zu Schaden kommen
sagt der militär-experte und
Politikwissenschaftler Gustav gräßel
vielen Dank von mir vielen Dank auch von
vielen Userinnen und Usern die sehr
dankbar sind für ihre Einschätzungen zum
Lage in der Ukraine und auch zu
Einschätzung der Pentagon liegt vielen
Dank Herr gräßel und vielen Dank an Sie
liebe Userinnen und User fürs Mitmachen
und mit kommentieren und Fragen und wir
sagen tschüss von uns hier bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]